walking down a path where enslaved
Africans once marched in Chains headed
to America is the United States first
black vice president Kamala Harris on a
visit to what was a major hub for the
Atlantic slave trade in Ghana the tour
guide explains many of the captives
didn't see a way out and believed only
death would bring them freedom
it's not only about our past but about
our destiny and our future
that we must learn from it in a way that
we make the ancestors proud
more than just a charm offensive Harris
is on a week-long three-nation tour of
Africa an attempt to counter the growing
influence of China and Russia on the
continent Russia has signed new military
cooperation agreements with 17 African
countries China is a continent's largest
trading Parker with two trillion dollars
in investments in construction projects
after the U.S Africa Summit last
December Harris is one of several senior
White House officials to visit the
continent in recent months marking a
contrast with the previous Trump
Administration the United States is
trying to catch up to to Russia and
China this is the most recent iteration
of a supposed policy with regard to
Africa but the U.S has not demonstrated
that in terms of investment in terms of
sustained engagement uh with various
African governments after Ghana Harris
traveled to Tanzania to meet the
nation's first female president she then
went on to Zambia promising more
American Investment but with 21 African
countries on the verge of bankruptcy
their leaders say they want debt relief
first what is keeping us down for now
Vice President
is the debt over hand we carry a dead
burden that really
is making it difficult for us
to continue with our restructuring
process of the economy Kamala Harris
announced more than seven billion
dollars in private sector in U.S
government commitments during her trip
it is an attempt to renew relations from
this shared history Harris says the
United States would build a common
future alongside Africans
Nicholas Hawk Al Jazeera